foreign
thank you please be seated
welcome to this joint press conference
by President of the Republic of Finland
seouli ninista and president of the
United States Joe Biden we will begin
with statements by the presidents
thank you and could afternoon
excellent that we have this kind of a
big hole in there Castle plenty of you
here
first of all job Mr President I want to
thank you for
eating Finland we have had possibilities
of meeting each other quite often during
uh I could hear even better yep and by
the way first time we met also in
Helsinki I was the speaker of parliament
when you visited
um I remember
so we have had a lot of discussions
during the last couple years I want to
once again thank you for the strong
support you have given all the time
the new era in Phoenix security policy
has begun and you will be one of those
who wrote it to history
I also want to thank you for
the Wilderness meeting
it was
very
touching to feel the unity between
others and I think it was greatly
created by you
we had possibilities of discussing
bilaterally today I took up the
negotiations of our
defense cooperation agreement we are
going to continue our security
discussion by that and that is of vital
importance to Finland
in the same time also Sweden and Denmark
are having similar discussions and at
the end it seems that all the five
Nordic countries will have a bilateral
agreement with USA
technology is one of the key words for
the future
there are elements like artificial
intelligence quotum technology Sky
technology all that is
[Music]
leading our way to the Future and we
have
to make sure that it's leading our way
in a very secure way
and that
possibility of those who know how and
that is why it is very important to
coordinate and cooperate with
with knowledge and resources forward in
this sector
we also had to discussion on our
neighbor
and I think that we both share similar
views the boring Ukraine was also
discussed we
both see that
we will continue support to Ukraine
which is defending not only herself but
also all the values we represent in the
western world
we also had a
meeting with the Nordic family it is a
tradition which started during President
Obama's time and it has been very
valuable tool for us to get in better
understand each other's
security and Technology they're also
discussed there and a lot of
time and thoughts were presented on
environmental issues
so
again
been great to have you here
well thank you Mr President it's been
great to be here look it's an honor
to be with you and our other Nordic
friends we just finished
I would suggest very productive of the
U.S Nordic leaders Summit on the heels
of the historic NATO Summit Vilnius and
where Finland took its place at the
table
as as our newest Ally I've always been
friends with our newest official Ally
member of NATO and I also want to thank
Minister Christensen of Sweden who will
soon meet
Prime Minister store in Norway she uh
we've had a great relationship and
Frederickson of Denmark and uh the
ministry of Copeland's daughter of
Ireland our daughter of Ireland you can
tell us afford it is slip on thinking of
home uh the daughter of Iceland and uh
um and I I want to say I think we've had
a very productive Summit we discussed Mr
President where we stand at an
inflection point in history where the
decisions we make now are going to
determine the course of the history for
the next four five six decades and this
week we affirmed how Finland and the
United States together together with
allies and partners are working a
lockstep to set us on a stronger safer
and more secure path not just for Europe
not just for NATO but for the world
and Vilnius NATO met with 33 Nations for
the first 31 Nations for the first time
we showed the world that our alliance is
more united than ever and soon it'll be
32 allies thanks to an agreement with
turkey to move Sweden's accession
protocols forward and uh as capable
partners and committed democracy both
Finland and Sweden are going to add
significantly to the strength security
and uh and unanimity of NATO and a
stronger NATO it makes the entire world
stronger Mr President as your ally we
want the people of Finland to know the
United States is committed to Finland to
committed to Nato and those commitments
are Rock Solid that we're defend every
inch of NATO territory and that includes
Finland obviously
second over the past week reaffirmed our
unwavering support for the brave people
of Ukraine as they defend their country
against Russia's brutal and inhumane
attacks
our allies and partners around the world
understand that this fight is not only a
fight for the future of Ukraine it's
about sovereignty security and freedom
itself I want you to think about what
would happen if we didn't do anything
what has likely to happen in the rest of
Europe if we did nothing
so this week NATO's officially elevated
our relationship with Ukraine allies
also agreed to lift the membership
action plan it's usually required before
you could be admitted and from Ukraine
and it's created a path for membership
for Ukraine as it continues to make
progress on the necessary Democratic and
security reforms required of every NATO
member we also made clear to president
zielinski that we're not waiting for
NATO membership to be finalized to
commit to long-term security of Ukraine
leaders of the G7 together issued a new
joint Declaration of support for Ukraine
a declaration I was glad to see the
Nordic Nations immediately welcome and
supported
it's going to launch a process open to
any Nation to negotiate bilateral
security agreements with with Ukraine
until they're officially members of NATO
it'll not only ensure that your crane
can defend itself today but it will
deter future aggression as well with the
capable Force across ant Land Air and
Sea from their friends
and finally at every stop of in every
Summit on this trip we focus on using
the power of partnership to take on the
challenges that matter most to the
people's lives in our countries in the
United Kingdom we brought together
public private and philanthropic
Partners to discuss ways to unlock
clearly trillions of private dollars in
finance to fight climate change in
Lithuania NATO allies met in the EU and
our Pro our indo-pacific partners to
continue advancing our work on terrorism
cyber threats resilience and so much
more and here in Finland at our U.S
Nordic leader Summit reaffirmed our
commitment to stand together power to
power clean energy transition
preserve Regional security promote
democratic values and to Pioneer the
Technologies of the future from Quantum
Computing to advanced communication
systems so we did it together
Mr President in this critical moment in
history this inflection point the world
is watching to see will we do the hard
work that matters to forge a better
future
will We Stand Together will we stand
with one another
will we stay committed to our course
this week Finland of the United States
and our allies and partners said in
resounding loud yes
yes we'll step up yes we'll stand
together and yes we'll keep working
toward a stronger safer and more secure
world so Mr President thank you again
for having me here as partners friends
and allies I look forward to our work
together in the years ahead and it's
been a real pleasure getting to know you
even better thank you
thank you now we have time for questions
we shall we start with uh
you yes Public Broadcasting Service my
question is for Mr President Biden uh
the political volatility of U.S remains
big worry for European Partners
meanwhile back in Washington a
bipartisan group of senators has
repeatedly failed to pass through Senate
a bill that would prevent the U.S
presidents in the future from
withdrawing from NATO without tennis
approval what actually
about what I'm sorry I didn't hear the
last part of your question uh in
Washington a bipartisan group of
senators has repeatedly failed to pass
through Senate a law that would prevent
future U.S presidents one from
withdrawing from NATO without Senate's
approval what actions will you take to
assure Finland that U.S will remain a
reliable NATO partner for decades to
come I absolutely guarantee it there is
no question there's overwhelming support
from the American people there's
overwhelming support from the members of
the Congress both House and Senate in
both parties notwithstanding the fact
there's some extreme elements of one
party
we will stand together the American
people known for those since the end of
World War II and the formation of NATO
that our security rests in the unanimity
among European and transatlantic
Partners us and so this is you know no
one can guarantee the future but this is
the best bet anyone could make
and my second question on that note to
uh Mr President ninista hearing this
answer that no one can guarantee a
future are you worried that the
political instability in U.S will cause
issues in the alliance in the future let
me be clear I didn't say we didn't
guarantee it we couldn't guarantee the
future you can't tell me whether you're
going to be able to go home tonight no
one can be sure what they're going to do
I'm saying as sure as anything could
possibly be said about American foreign
policy we will stay connected to Nato
connected to Nato beginning middle and
end we're a transatlantic partnership
that's what I've said
it seems that the president has answered
your problems but I have to tell you
that
during this process
I met approximately a president many
times but I would say about 50
people from Congress and synod
and I think the message
was quite clear quite United and I have
no reason to doubt about USA policies in
the future
let me say one more thing
we learned a hard lesson
peace and Security in Europe
is essential to U.S security and peace
the idea that there could be conflict in
Europe among our friends and us not
engaged has never happened in modern
history that's why we're staying
together
next question president pardon
oh I've called on somebody I'm sorry
um Wall Street Journal Andrew
thank you Mr President
you've said that Ukraine shouldn't enter
NATO until after the war is over are you
concerned that all of those commas could
motivate Putin to keep the war going or
discourage him from from entering peace
negotiations and is there a serious risk
that this war to drag on for years and
do you see any path toward the War
ending with Putin still in power
first of all
no one can join NATO while a war a war
is going on where a NATO nation is being
attacked because that guarantees that
we're in a war and we're in a third
world war
so that it's not about whether or not
they should or should have joined it's
about when they can join and they will
join NATO
the issue of whether or not
um
this is going to keep Putin from
continuing to fight the answer is
Putin's already lost the war Putin has a
real problem how does he move from here
what does he do and so the idea that
there's going to be what vehicle is used
he could end the war tomorrow he could
just say I'm out but what agreement is
ultimately reached depends upon Putin
and what he decides to do but there
there is no possibility of him winning
the war in Ukraine he's already lost
that war imagine if even if anyway he's
already lost that war
just on the question of a concern about
going on for years
is there a possibility that there's a
Salesman the question of whether the war
could go on for years is there a
possibly there's a stalemate and can
continue for quite some time
well I don't think the work can go on
for years for two reasons number one I
don't think that the
that Russians could uh
could maintain the war forever number
one in terms of their resources and
capacity
number two uh I think that there is
going to be a circumstance where
uh eventually uh
President Putin is going to decide it's
not in the interest of Russia
economically politically or otherwise to
continue this war but I can't predict
exactly how that happens my hope is and
my expectation is you'll see that
Ukraine makes a significant progress on
their offensive and that it generates in
a negotiated settlement somewhere along
the line
and I have a question for the Finnish
president but I would be remiss if I
didn't raise my colleague Evan
gershkovic who's been in prison for more
than 100 days I just wondered if you had
an update on on the process for trying
to get him out of prison and if you're
serious about a prisoner Exchange
I'm serious about prisoner exchange I'm
serious about doing all we can to free
Americans
and legally held in Russia or anywhere
else for that matter and that process is
underway
like I told we are discussing on GCA the
defense
cooperation agreement and it has a lot
of elements they are still open but we
are open on negotiations and I know that
our counterpart is also very open so
let us see
next question goes to president ninista
please
thank you Mr President and my question
is for
Mr President Biden
or should I just say President Biden
you have repeatedly talked about
finlandization becoming natoization of
Finland
now based on us what they should you
have repeatedly talked about
finlandization
becoming natoization of Finland
based on your long experience how does
that change finland's place in the world
well first of all the context in which I
said that was
the gentleman who occupies a seat on the
other side of your Border in Moscow
said he wanted I said he wanted the
finalization of NATO as it was more
likely to get the natoization of Finland
that's what that's the context to which
that was said and what was the second
part of your question
I asked
how has finland's position in the world
changed
during
this NATO membership program it was
already a strong vibrant Nation
I think what finland's joining NATO
does in Sweden as well when the Nordic
countries are all members of of NATO
just makes the world safer
significantly increases the prospect
that there is less likely to be War
s we're deadly Earnest about the notion
we'll defend every single inch of NATO
territory
and now we're going to we're on a way of
getting to 32 NATO Nations
that's a significant commitment and so
the likelihood of Any Nation voluntarily
deciding they're going to attack and one
of the Nations or Finland is highly
unlikely and so but if it if it were to
they understand they're not just
attacking Finland they're attacking 31
other countries
next question President Biden please
I'm sorry I guess it's Arlette CNN
oh thank you Mr President we've seen
more disarray with Russian generals most
recently with the firing of a general
who criticized the defense Ministry this
following that Rebellion by pagosian
does this raise any new concerns about
Putin potentially doing more drastic
things regarding Ukraine like nuclear
weapons or potentially against the U.S
like election interference
first of all they're already interfered
in American elections so that would not
be anything new they did that last time
they tried to
but with regard to I I don't think
there's any real Prospect you never know
but of Putin using nuclear weapons not
only has the west but China and the rest
of the world have said that's don't go
there don't go there number two number
three I think that uh
determining what happens to purgosia and
what happens to Vilnius I mean excuse me
what happens when we discuss this in
Vilnius is uh God only knows what what
he's likely uh to do well I'm not even
sure we're not even sure where he is and
what relationship he has if I were here
I'd be careful what I ate I'd be keeping
my eye on my menu but I'll Kitty aside I
I who knows I don't know I don't think
any of us know for certain what the
future of fergusion is in Russia and and
so I I don't know how to answer that
question beyond that
and if I could also ask you something
about happening back home you're seeing
the GOP grappling with tying abortion
rights to defense issues including a
block on Military promotions by Senator
tuberville what does this say about U.S
military Readiness Readiness and would
you be willing to talk with toberville
to try to work out some solution
I'd be willing to talk to him if I
thought there's any possibility of
changing this ridiculous position he has
he's jeopardizing U.S security by what
he's doing I expect the Republican party
to stand up
stand up and do something about it
they've been their power to do that the
idea that we don't have a chairman of
the Joint Chiefs of Staff the idea that
we have all these all these promotions
that are in advance right now we don't
know what's going to happen the idea
that we're injecting into
fundamental foreign policy decisions
what in fact as a domestic social debate
on social issues is bizarre I don't ever
recall that happening ever and it's it's
a it's just totally irresponsible in my
view and uh I I just think that
I mean
I'm confident that the mainstream
Republican party uh no longer does not
support what he's doing but they got to
stand up and be counted That's How It
Ends
and for president nidisto you've been
working on fortifying the fence along
the border between Finland and Russia is
there anything that you're seeing
recently that concerns you and also as a
leader who shares a border with Russia
what more do you want to see done to
deter Putin
uh during the beginning of our
application process surely we had to
make sure first trying to figure out
every possible
negative action we might meet and surely
how we respond from that and we were
very careful on that work so
moment situation is quite calm hope it
remains as such
but I just want to tell you that
Finnish people do feel more secure at
the moment we have 80 percent of
population supporting NATO membership
and more than 80 percent who say that we
will also protect our allies that's the
finished position
thank you this concludes the press
conference thank you very much
[Applause]
foreign